um
let me try and beat this guy alexander
in jitch
if that's how we pronounce it i think
he's
being coached by by miroswitch
injured she's supposed to be like the
tallest grandmaster in the world
it's really tall
[Music]
um okay so i'm just gonna go with bishop
e5
i think this guy as i said is being
ghost morozovic so he's
i'm sure he has a bunch of interesting
ideas and
and um
now so what's the story here what do you
do a5 or d4
[Music]
or what i don't know i'm just gonna
castle
just gonna castle
so he goes a6 bishop e2
so this was what i had against
against ray yi here the other day
it looks pretty moronic to
like it feels like i'm playing some sort
of
very sicilian but there are some points
to it
not gonna disclose all of them but
i can say i can safely say that it's not
as stupid as it looks
which would be of course
a bit of a shame because it looks kind
of stupid
i mean i'm just playing this without
thinking
well this should work right bishop f3
i mean i can do a number of things i can
go just bishop f3 du5
attacking the queen then queen d3 has to
go rook 87
go [ __ ] b3 followed by a5 then
i think with with decent compensation
uh i can also take a d6
which b2 d7 knight e2 later on
castles maybe b3 followed by bishop a3
should be slightly better
and i could take an f6 bishop f6 seems
to be forced queen d6
bishop b2 knight e2
and
also their white seems to be slightly
better
so i think it's a pleasant choice
okay whatever
this just feels like the most sort of
prince the principles of the
the options that i have
like i'm actually trying not to be
not to just to be slightly better but
hopefully like quite a bit better
and he's like he's burning time like
there's no tomorrow
so that's a good thing
for me that is not necessarily for him
so for the moment he's got an extra pawn
but
not like a whole lot of joy
so what can i do here ap6 bishop b6
i could go rook a6 win the pawn bike but
then he gets to weaken my pawn structure
with
bush b3 so i i don't really want to do
that
i can go bishop c5
maybe what he did was clever
he burned a lot of time but probably he
came up with something decent
so let me try and now i mean i just
burnt all my time myself
and i'm not even not up on time anymore
which means that i will have to play
away
well in order to win but i still have
pressure here because i'm threatening
bishop c6
after recastles and hopefully i will get
to take on
take on b6 with um some
potentially fairly mighty
passers
um i think just rook d2
can i be really arrogant and just go h3
okay i don't have time i'm just gonna
just gonna liquidate a bit yeah rook d6
sorry
uh i didn't like that one and i cannot
take an a6
so this is not a blunder because there
would be background issues for him as
well
but no it's not going to be easy to win
of course
oh boy
don't know what i'm doing here
okay he's playing too slowly
now he's losing a pawn
position is still a draw but it's not
that easy for him
okay and he lost some time but at this
point
at this point he actually had to play
very well to
to make a draw which is already
or kind of well which was already
a massive achievement for me